Eric Boss here with another new rock
stars hot take the latest poster for
Spider-Man across the spiderverse
reveals 40 spider people which I broke
down another video that you should watch
but this includes a spectacular
Spider-Man sun spider Charlotte web and
I think Japanese Spider-Man takuyo
Yamashiro the two I'm most interested in
can only be seen in the corners of
international posters the Chinese
posters showing a lanky Spider-Man who
looks roughly the height of Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man and a Turkish poster
showing a Peter with a gold chest emblem
that looks like the integrated suit from
Spider-Man no way home Andrew Garfield
Peter is already a Multiverse traveler
but Tom Hall and Peter from the MCU how
the hell did he get here did Miguel
O'Hara show up and give him a risk Gizmo
to join a spider Force where he would
have friends who actually know who he is
is this all to set up a live action
Spider-Man 4 where Tom Holland Peter
would team up with Miles Morales let me
know what you think And subscribe to new
rockstars